What is the story behind the
logo that you use in your intros?
Where did it come from?
That's,
that logo is called the meaning of music
and it's actually a sculpture that I
made in 1985 that's about
five and a half feet by half,
five and a half feet and
about eight inches thick.
And it's made out of foam core,
which is this bed.
It's a sub.
It's a material that's often used as a
backing for paintings or for when you get
them framed,
it's it's styrofoam sheet about a quarter
of an inch thick with paper on both
sides and you can cut it very
accurately with an exacto knife.
And so what I did was
make a stack of those uh,
uh,
those foam core sheets about eight inches
high and it made the thing in quarters
and so that it would fit together on the
wall because it would have been too big
to maneuver easily.
And,
um,
it's a very complicated,
image.
It's actually a three
dimensional representation of a,
it's a three dimensional representation
of a two dimensional representation of a
four dimensional object.
And that four dimensional
object you could think of as
it's a representation of time and space.
And I can tell you,
I kind of have to hint at
what the painting means.
It or the sculpture,
it means the same thing that music
means to know how music unfolds and then
something else unfolds within it.
And then it unfolds again within it,
like a rose opening into the,
into the day or like a lotus flower that
sort of comes up from the darkest steps
up through the dark water
and then blooms on the,
on the surface of the water and the sun.
And that's where the Buddha,
you know,
um,
what would you say?
Symbol symbolically rest.
So can imagine that thing opening and
then imagine that that's what that
painting is an image of.
And that's the same thing as music.
So it's a Mandela image.
And for young,
the Mandela was a symbol of the self
and the self was something that unfolds
like music,
which is actually why we
like music and it's like the,
the rose,
the rose that you see that the geometric
rose that you see in stained glass,
it's the same thing.
Um,
that's the Stain Glass Window
that Pinocchio was reprehensible.
Compatriot.
Um,
what's his name?
Lamp.
Wick breaks when he's in pleasure island
that he throws a rock to destroy the
model home to demolish the
substructure of Western civilization.
So I had a very intense religious
experience at one point when I was
contemplating that.
So when I drew the image to begin with,
I drew it in about 10 minutes,
kind of rough.
And then I use a straight
edge to straighten it all
open and a protractor to or
a compass to make the curves.
But I drew it very quickly
and I'd been thinking about,
I've been reading young
a lot at that point,
like fruit for months,
months of intense reading.
And that image you sort
of popped out of me very,
um,
very suddenly.
But it took about three months
to make the actual image.
And then I had only a quarter of it
hanging on my wall because it was so big.
And I had finished it after
about three months of work.
So this was back in 1985 and it was a
graduate student and I was listening to
the Jupiter symphony,
which is the piece of music that I use,
um,
that was used for the intro to my,
to my videos.
And it's a Mozart symphony.
And this happened,
man.
So this happened.
So I was really watching that Mandela,
that quarter,
Mandela,
that I have made intensely and
quite listening to the music,
trying to understand what the
music music was signifying,
you know,
because music has intrinsic meaning,
which is a very strange thing.
Now,
the part of the reason for that is that
language has meaning and our language
has a musical quality,
right?
And that's process most of by the right
hemisphere so that when people speak,
there's a,
there's a melody in their language.
And that carries a lot
of the emotional import.
And then what musicians have done
is figured out how to use that,
that,
that musical faculty,
let's call it that no one's semantic w
musical faculty to sort of purely denote
meaning.
That's part of what music means.
And so,
but I was still trying to
understand what the meaning was.
You know what,
because it's nonverbal,
the meaning of music.
And I was trying to figure
out how to articulate that.
And that's partly why I made the,
the sculpture was to get a grip on
it and to understand it in anyways,
I was,
uh,
really,
really concentrating hard on that.
Mandela and,
and that sculpture.
And I had been working on it
intensely for about three months.
And also that's a lot of
meditation on a single idea.
And I was standing in my living room and
then had this very strange experience.
I,
and I can't explain this properly because
there's no way of really describing
it,
but I'll do my best.
So you know,
when those renaissance
painting sometimes you see,
well first of all you see great cloud,
great,
great sunny skies with,
with massive,
uh,
what stupendous impressive bills of
clouds and then light shining through the
sunlight shining through in streams.
Sometimes that's captured very
beautifully but especially English later,
later artists usually that or
later than the renaissance.
But you see it in
renaissance paintings too.
And you all,
you also see in,
in,
in renaissance paintings,
especially in the earlier
phase of the renaissance,
the sky opening up in God sort of
peering fourth through the clouds.
And that's exactly what seemed to
happen to me is that I had this sense,
it was like a vision,
although I was still in
my living room in Newark,
but inside the theater of,
in my imagination,
I could feel the,
the sky opening up now
and it wasn't the sky,
it was,
I would say the only way I
can let you think about it,
that was something like another dimension.
And then I could feel this
force descend upon me,
which I think was something that,
you know,
would have been considered classically
something like the holy ghost,
I suppose.
And it filled me with
this intense sense of,
of,
of Paradise,
a paradise.
I don't know how to say it,
uh,
while it was like being
in heaven for some,
some,
some brief period of time and I
could feel myself transformed,
transmuted as a consequence
of this experience.
And it was as if I was in the
presence of something that was living,
you know,
and I suppose that was an experience
of God if you want to put it that way.
Um,
that's certainly what it seemed like.
And,
and I felt that I could live that way.
I could live transfigured like
that permanently if I desired it.
And I thought,
my God,
I wouldn't be able to walk down the
street in this sort of elevated state,
let's say.
I don't know how I would act.
I don't know how he would
interact with people.
I don't know how people
would interact with me.
I just don't think that I could do it.
And then I felt that
whatever had descended,
it seemed that as if it was sorrowful and,
and it,
and it departed from me slowly and,
um,
with no,
like with no punitive intent.
And I wouldn't say with
any dissatisfaction,
it was as if the gift
had been offered did,
I wasn't in no position to receive.
And,
uh,
I went,
I talked to my wife soon afterwards.
I shook for about physically for
about half an hour after that,
uh,
experience.
Like,
like I was shaking,
you know,
like,
like he shake after a car accident if
you've ever been in a car accident.
And my pupils were completely dilated
and I had a couple of experiences like
that,
like echoes of it a couple
of times after that.
And so,
anyways,
that was a very,
very powerful experience.
I've certainly never forgotten that.
And,
um,
well,
you know,
I dunno.
I don't know what to think about that.
I mean,
God only knows what the
world is really like,
that's for sure.
And I've had a variety of very strange
experiences that have convinced me that
we know very little about anything.
So.